je ne sais pas si il ya de l'eau dans le
gaz comme vous l'affirmez dans votre
courrier comme va tenter de nous prouver
dans un instant gérard pas bio mais
notre spécialiste du sondage express au
coin de la rue c'est branché sur 2000
volts pour faire le va-et-vient micro à
la main et je vous jure que six
interlocuteurs si certains
interlocuteurs en tout cas pour vous
paraître disons entre guillemets à la
masse aucune des réponses n'a été prise
de force
si je vous parle de prise de force ben
c'est un peu dégueulasse tacot les
maquis guns n' roses ainsi on est
rarement son poste ils sont une lui
apprend les reloge le lendemai
recommence j'en garde à vue pendant les
jours et sans manches et après on vient
de me cambrioler comme ils l'ont fait
chez moi dans ma caravane c'est
dégueulasse être branché à la main est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que ça
circule pas très bien maintenant
maintenant la petite tête c'est une
erreur je pense que être branché à l'âme
à souhait tout faire de l'élitisme dans
les deux cas c'est pas le
c'est parce qu'il convient quand je vous
parle du va-et-vient voyez ce que je
veux dire
oui très bien oui qu'est ce que c'est
c'est des choses qu'on ne parle pas
comme ça dans la rue ces choses intimes
ça c'est pas maintenant quand je vous
parle duval vient classique voyez ce que
je veux dire oui qu'est ce que c'est
pour faire ça traditionnellement jeu
point peut-être un quart d'heure une
demi-heure sur ça
voyez ce que je veux dire quand je parle
de va et vient qu'est ce que c'est
basset s'est classé que c'est normal
c'est à dire que pensez-vous du
va-et-vient
je suis contre les homosexuels
le branchement vous voyez ce que c'est
oui ceux qui s'y colle alors il vaut
mieux un branchement individuel ont un
branchement collectif que pensez-vous du
principe de la conduite forcée
je suis ni pour ni contre seulement la
personne qui a fait un choix comme un
abbé par exemple ne peut pas se promener
facilement rue saint-denis ou aborder
des filles comme un agent de police ne
peut pas faire du vol à la tire ou se
chahuter dans la rue devant tout le
monde
voyez-vous ce quel tarif dégressif
monsieur dégressif c'est pour nous
enlever les graisses tous là où ça aux
vêtements aux pantalons à la veste sur
tout ça dans quelques s'est encastré
c'est une ablation du prépuce
comment ça se fait c'était une incision
que ça avec 10 tours y avait qu un truc
comme ça qu'est ce qu'il faut faire une
saignée pour encastrer puisque nom déjà
voyez vous ce qu'est la baguette
électrique monsieur oui oui j'ai déjà
mangé cette vague atteint qu'est ce que
c'est c'est pas croustillants comme la
baguette au feu de bois sa photo fait le
même coup pour paris y à quoi vous sert
la terreur chez vous bientôt on a coupé
les colzas les blés les orges alors quel
type de résistance ou connaissances sur
la résistance pendant la guerre 39 45
voyez vous ce qu'est le poteau
électrique oui qu'est ce que c'est c'est
pot-au-feu fait hésiter et alors et
alors c'est formidable
oui c'est formidable en effet le poteau
électrique je crois qu'il ya rien de
vieux même si ses attaches un petit peu
à la casserole
on avait fait ce sondage parce qu'on
s'était rendu compte que dans une eau de
l'être nous que les spectateurs ne
comprenaient pas toujours ce qu'on leur
écrivait sur les devis voilà